as a woman and somebody going into the
healthcare field I personally don't it's
on your opinion on abortion I personally
don't think that like I could have an
abortion just because morally I feel
like for myself it wouldn't be the right
choice but how do you defend your
opinion as a white well religious man
how do you defend your hat like telling
under woman what she can deal with
because legal things are a source evil
even if I'm a white well-off religious
man and good things
this is one of these this is one of
these identity politics points that I
really I mean I don't mean to come down
harshly on you I don't but it is a point
that I really have serious moral qualms
with I think it's quite quite terrible
the reason being that the people who
were fighting against enslavement of
black people were a bunch of well-off
white men for the most part right and
those people were saying this is a moral
sin this is a moral blot they weren't
living in the south they didn't know
implantations they didn't live the lives
of the plantation owners that this is
evil and we are here to stop it right
when you see something that you think is
morally wrong happening especially when
you're talking about the taking of a
human life egg listen I think that I
think that you shouldn't go around
randomly killing homeless people I just
have this view I'm not a homeless person
most of the people who randomly kill
homeless people are probably not of my
economic strata my religious view or my
I don't know whether they're of my skin
color or not I have no idea what the
what the actual sociological breakdown
of homeless killer serial murderers is
but but I would suggest that my identity
has nothing to do with what is right or
wrong
and this is what Western civilization
used to be about Western civilization
used to be about the idea that yes I'm
not a woman in the healthcare field but
you and I can have a conversation about
what's right and wrong because this is
the nature of human reason the nature of
human reason the nature of right and
wrong is that you and I can talk about
what's right and wrong and that I don't
retreat into my identity if we cannot
retreat into our identity and our
morality is now centered around that
identity morality doesn't exist at all
we break down into a society of
fragmented atoms where I can't even say
like you're torturing a puppy in your
backyard I have nothing to say about
that I'm not a white woman who's in the
healthcare field I'm not going to do
that I don't I don't
I refuse to surrender the idea that I
can have a moral stance on issues that
are of concern to society and of concern
to the to the well-being of the United
States simply because of the color of my
skin or the nature of my genitalia and
honestly I believe any of you that feels
differently is sexist racist and bigoted